[MUSIC]
Containers, microservices, kubernetes.
These are a few of the hottest
buzzwords floating around.
But what's driving the hype?
In the last decade, user demand for
always on applications
have grown exponentially.
If you go to your favorite site,
you expect, no,
demand it to be up 24/7 globally.
No exceptions.
Many developers have chosen application
patterns such as microservices,
to meet this need.
But what about the infrastructure
to support these always on apps?
This course is going to show you,
step by step, from theory to production,
how to meet these demands using
tools that are available today.
I'm your host, Carter Morgan.
And like you, I'm new to this
world of microservices and
the advanced infrastructures
used to support that.
So I reached out to my good friend,
Kelsey Hightower.
You may know him as Mr. Kubernetes,
AKA, a sys admin who can code.
Kelsey will be serving
as our industry expert,
giving us deep insights into
the solutions we'll be covering.
Additionally, we'll be hearing from
the legendary former cloud architect of
Netflix.
The guy who helped make microservices
mainstream, Adrian Cockcroft.
And he will be sharing his insights
on the evolution of applications
in modern day infrastructure.
But before we go any further, let's hear
from Kelsey on who this course is for.
>> You know Carter, this course is for
anyone doing operations.
Whether you're sys admin, or
developer, or anyone new to the field,
looking to mystify the idea of
managing applications at scale.
Many of you may be familiar with
automation tools such as Puppet,
Chef, or Ansible.
We're going to build on that knowledge,
and introduce you to the world of
distributed systems, and take your
idea of automation to the next level.
>> This will be taught through
a collection of hands on tasks,
using industry standard tooling
like Docker and Kubernetes.
By the end of this course,
you'll know the ins and
outs of the cloud application Lifecycle,
from packaging it into a container,
to managing into production.
Kelsey, I know a lot of people
are excited about this, but
can you give a sneak peek
about what to expect.
>> First, we're going to start with
the basics of understanding modern day
applications, and how a new design
pattern such as microservices,
has driven the need for
more robust infrastructure.
Once we have a solid
understanding of an application,
we'll shift focus towards
how to package and
distribute our apps, using the Docker
image format and container technologies.
Then we'll really up our game, to
running applications using distributed
platform that allows us to start small,
and
scale to the levels of internet giants
such as Google, Facebook, and Netflix.
>> Where do I sign up?
I don't know about you, but
that's exactly what I'm looking for.
Let's go ahead and
get started, shall we?
[BLANK_AUDIO]